this year's sakharov prize for freedom
of thought will be awarded to the
imprisoned russian opposition figure
alexey navalny for his fight for
democracy in russia his daughter daria
will receive the award on his behalf
parliament will adopt its position on
the new digital markets act it's set to
call for stricter regulation of the
so-called gatekeepers of the internet to
better protect consumers and their data
the rules would apply to powerful giants
like search engines social networks and
advertisers
ahead of the eu leaders summit later
this month meps will debate the pandemic
situation they're also expected to voice
concerns about how global supply chains
have been affected and examine the
rollout of covid recovery funds
meps are expected to call for more
action to combat cyber violence against
women and lgbtiq people proposals
include harmonized criminal sanctions
across the eu for gender-based cyber
violence like cyber stalking and
harassment and the recording of images
of sexual assault
parliament is set to vote on making 2022
the european year of youth
young people have been hit hard by the
pandemic and meps want to hear what they
have to say getting them more involved
in policy making